hey everybody and welcome to wild ride
with stevo
man do we have a cool dude on this
week's episode
this guy is a rapper he's a chef he's a
tv star a movie star
and straight up he don't give a [ __ ] so
let's get into it
ladies and gentlemen action bronson
yeah dude i'm here finally bro what's
going on stevo
doing great man i want you to meet my
co-host scott randolph
what's going on god what's up my brother
how you feeling very good so where are
you at right now
i'm in brook nom cool man brook knob
green point just kicking it right now
just had a beautiful day
it was like i was 16 again i was running
around with my wife around the city
making out in little enclaves good man
uh riding city bikes that's cool
first time ever it was [ __ ] weird but
i liked it got a good pump
yeah you'd look like you might be a
little bit under the influence of
marijuana
a touch right on man
a smidgen
[Laughter]
that's great dude and uh
so you've been pretty heavy promoting
your new book
as well as your new season of [ __ ]
that's delicious
listen to be fair i don't give a [ __ ]
about promotion i just like to talk good
[ __ ] with people
i didn't mean i didn't mean for it to
[ __ ] you know [ __ ] always comes
around this
around book time but i don't give a [ __ ]
i'm just happy to be here epic man well
i appreciate that dude thank you for
this
real man it's good yeah that the fact
that you're
uh new york times bestseller two times
over
particularly interesting to me because
i'm working now on my second book and uh
yeah
yeah i expect i'll be two times over new
york times best seller as well
you [ __ ] better be that's what it's
about i mean listen at the end of the
day
the editor's happy everyone sites now
i'm just watching fights like you like
i'm just immersed in [ __ ] yeti pro
hosting
[ __ ] all kinds of crazy [ __ ]
geeky cicada saying [ __ ] yeah dude man
yeah i i heard that you're a big big
mma fan i'd [ __ ] love it dude
heavy duty yeah how long does it take
you to write a new york time bestseller
i didn't write one word it all came from
my mind did all these things happen in
life
i did shove a toothbrush up my ass
because
i didn't like the woman that my friend
was with
and she had given me you know bad vibes
she talked badly to me so i did
brush my [ __ ] with her brush
no one else could write that [ __ ] with
me does it happen
so yeah it doesn't really take long but
i it was a long tedious thing because
it was really supposed to be a self-help
book so i was talking about [ __ ] like
that
i don't really know how it became what
it was well
i mean without with all the weight loss
and [ __ ] that was kind of
the deal right is that sort of what it
all tied into
like food addiction and struggling with
i mean it kind of tied into that but
it all it was all supposed to be like a
self-help book like a confidence book
but i was 400 [ __ ] pounds like
ordering
three different meals while doing this
it was ridiculous
yeah it was a [ __ ] show so i don't you
know
i didn't it kind of made me turn the
mirror on myself that
this is the one bright light about it
because it was definitely tedious to
write because
i hate [ __ ] reading the [ __ ] back
that i said i was like wow man and i'll
[ __ ] like
this is horrible i sound like a schmuck
like let's can i
read let's re-say this like did i say
this i'm [ __ ]
i'm arguing with the with my with my
with my writer like yo
what the [ __ ] why'd you write this she's
like yo i this
you said it right here on tape
dude that's that's classic man so are
you gonna be doing an audiobook version
with your voice or no way
nah i threw a fit the other day and
threw everybody out from audible because
i didn't
i was just hated reading what i was
writing
so i threw everybody out nice dude
there's no audio book everybody gotta
[ __ ] read
it's only 150 pages you got to read this
[ __ ]
all right [ __ ] it no audio book i like
it
it's too easy so it's safe to say when
you're a new york time bestseller your
books everywhere
right people can just google the book
and
i don't know my experience with
my first book was that i made the new
york times bestseller list so i am a new
york times bestseller
but i was like [ __ ] maybe number 18
or something on the list like i was like
i was maybe i was number 12
for like one week and then the next 18
and then i was gone
and i didn't sell that many copies to
make the list
you know i i forget what it was but like
i think it's still a big
deal though because there's only 20
people and think about how many heads
write books
right like
one out of 20 heads that [ __ ] [ __ ]
weird amount of people write books so i
think it's pretty it's
it is what it pretty amazing when it's
unexpected you know that's really what
it's about
all these all unexpected accolades are
what it is
i think my first book [ __ ] that's
delicious debuted at four
yeah like i don't know what the [ __ ]
that means
well this one was ten yeah on the
non-fiction list right right right there
i would imagine non-fiction is a little
bit harder to get onto than
you know [ __ ] i don't know children's
literature
right right right do you get a phone
call that says that your
number or is it just you have to google
it or uh
publish is published i think the agent
the publisher of the agency or the
public the publisher or the agency
reached out to say
but dude i gotta circle back and say how
impressive that is because
of course you know i i heard all about
your weight loss that's been like a big
thing
and yeah nowhere yeah and you said that
you got a self-help book
so i kind of put it together it's like
oh he lost a lot of weight
and so then he thought well let me
inspire people by my
but it was actually the other way around
it's the prequel it has nothing
i was 400 pounds and it ended in the
beginning of the pandemic
exactly when i started getting my [ __ ]
together in march
book ended in march didn't try to set up
a sequel but kinda did
dad that's [ __ ] fantastic
thank you i don't know all this [ __ ]
kind of just happened like magic i'm
a [ __ ] i'm like houdini over here
pulling out [ __ ] book deals
it's awesome man um now i know you as a
rapper
and like you're how much of your rap is
actually rapping about food
i don't think it's much about rapping
about food it was always about
i remember when i started rapping it
wasn't i was in a kitchen
so i would think of ways to connect
some sort of drug dealing in food
calling the drugs hummus
you know just trying to get cute so
that's really how it all started because
i was in a kitchen and
i come from fine dining and i don't
think that there's you know i don't
think it was represented in the right
way it was always
linguine and [ __ ] lobster
that's hip-hop food i don't you know i
don't do hip-hop food
fettuccine alfredo how many times has
that been mentioned in the wrap
cheney alfred i don't know maybe that
shit's good
it's just a lot it's a lot yeah
duck and [ __ ] mr baklava talking about
hummus and pita bread
it's me [ __ ] i'm of the land you know
what i mean
that's why i call myself baklava there's
a lot of layers to me
[ __ ] out of my mind
i just thought of that you heard it here
first
i just love bach levi you know it's like
a childhood thing my grandmother used to
make and it was like
it was near and dear to me yeah that's
great man um
so you're working as a chef and then you
get injured and you're like oh [ __ ] i
can't work
so i'm gonna rap yeah i was rapping a
little bit on the side as a little pride
a little hobby
but then i was like someone paid me
someone from australia paid me to do a
verse
and from then on i was like [ __ ] this
let's go
i took it seriously i remember i stacked
up a bunch of money while i was still
injured and i was like yo this is the
most money i've ever had in my life
this is crazy all from doing verses and
doing different things and like little
it was wild so and when i was continuing
on huh what year was that
2010-2011
aha yeah so it's been a [ __ ] long
time man
god damn right but everything's over
yeah dude tell me about it
everything starts moving pretty quickly
at that point yeah and you end up
getting a record deal with
warner not really [ __ ] it wasn't that
fast it was more
it was more of a slow burn it was a slow
burn for me you know i
i kept it i kept it nice and underground
for a while and then it [ __ ]
and then i got the nice deal wasn't a
great one but it was a decent one
and then i ended up it was with warner
vice and then i ended up doing whatever
the [ __ ] i wanted on television with
vice so that ended up being
worth everything yeah i always like
asking the question
what do you do with your first major
paycheck you know the
what's the first thing you buy do you
buy a watch do you buy
ah i don't wear trinkets you know i
don't have any [ __ ] jewelry
that's great i have no jewels whatsoever
the first thing i ever bought with a rap
check was a [ __ ] 95
bmw 535 wagon
gold still got it sitting on
schmitz dropped down to the floor
heavy duty [ __ ] man i'm about to redo
the interior
nice i'm trying to i'm thinking about
going all vegan on the interior
good yeah it's too you know i remember i
was trying to buy a cadillac
at one point i wanted to buy one i
wanted to buy one and i was like hey man
[ __ ] i i want uh like no leather
and they were like oh well if you're
gonna get a cadillac with like
you know like fully loaded it has to
have leather i'm like that's a dumb
unheard of for them to even if that was
an unheard of request
yeah i like to avoid having leather in
my my [ __ ] man
yeah i feel you on that man but you they
use it in everything
you can't get a [ __ ] away from the
leather i got leather pants on for god's
sakes
like there's leather in my shorts
somehow
yeah dude so that's why i only wear swim
trunks and and flexible shorts
there's definitely no leather in that
yeah for sure
flexi flexi shorts is the best because
if you have to squat
then it's not gonna rip yeah dude and i
gotta just give you props
on calling your tv show [ __ ] that's
delicious
thanks bro yeah man listen you know
try to push the little envelope yeah and
keep it classy as well because you know
it's elegant
did they try to tell you you can't use
the word [ __ ]
i'm pretty sure that nobody tells action
bronson what he can
and cannot do and i'm also pretty sure
that he will do what he wants
and he will not do what he does not want
and you know what i do not
want to do is nick my balls
when i am shaving them because that used
to be a real major
problem with me i had the same clippers
that i would cut my hair with
that i was using on my balls and i would
be bleeding all over the place
but no longer man not since i teamed up
with manscape
and i have really exciting news that if
you thought
the manscaped lawnmower 3.0 was badass
they just came out with the 4.0 and i am
here to confirm
that it is far more awesome
than anything you've ever experienced in
your life
plus summer's here man it's time to be
sleek
and slim and not bushy you hear me
because when women go down there and
they find a bush you're out of there
but not if you're using the lawnmower
4.0
from manscape and that's right i'm going
to give you a great deal on it right now
you go to manscaped.com
and that gets you 20 off your order plus
free shipping
again for 20 off your lawnmower 4.0
and free shipping to anywhere in the
world go to
slash manscape.com and look good and
feel good this summer
now let's talk about telling action
bronson what to do
nah vice was all [ __ ] psyched about
it because it was you know
new and fresh and hot and whoa
and and now you got season five when did
season one start for that
[ __ ] i think 2015 or 16.
and how many it really started on the
internet first
with munchies my man chris grosso
and you know oh [ __ ] i know chris grosso
the indie spiritualist
yup exactly he's such an indie
spiritualist it's crazy
yeah i had a great time talking to him
he's a good dude
yeah he knows a lot about skating you
know he knows a lot about tattoos
he knows a lot about pizza yeah he's
good
yeah dude so i you know i just
i just did what i wanted man i don't
know i just everything that i do in life
i create my narrative man you know i do
everything i want
i'm not [ __ ] i'm not bound by
anything by anybody
i just do what i want i'm free to create
as
as i feel i like it man me too how many
how many times over have the people at
vice
like switched where you're like oh
there's a new person running vice this
week and then the next week oh we got a
new person running vice
yeah they they went through a couple of
cable things once they started doing the
cable [ __ ] it got all [ __ ] jerky
you know all kinds of different people
came through
whatever as long as i got to do my [ __ ]
i did the ancient alien show you know
where you just
people would just watch ancient aliens
with me and i'd smoke weed with all my
boys
like i literally brought all my friends
around the world
to do a food show and chill get paid and
chill
smoke [ __ ] do all kinds of things you
know
it's unbelievable i i look back at that
those are my greatest achievements being
able to bring
my friends along on the ride you know
like if i'm going on tour everyone comes
with us
i lost a lot of money doing all that
[ __ ] i don't give a [ __ ] though all
those memories were
it's all worth it nice man um with uh
with music with cooking
tv books how do the revenue streams
stack up is music on top it's got to be
right
nah they it all everything varies you
know it's all
they all work together they're like they
feed off each other you know
right i i do i have things here oh i've
got money over there i got things over
here i got things over there
you know what i mean yeah i'm always
moving and shaking there's always
there's always something happening i'm
always working i'm always working on
something there's always something next
oh dude yeah i never want to not have a
[ __ ] project that i'm all excited
about that's what i'm saying
is you know it's not it's not about
money man it's about [ __ ] keeping
busy and doing what you like like i
enjoy
doing this [ __ ] that's not busy work for
me it's like i wrote a wrap today
i just painted something before i got on
with you
nice [ __ ] hashed out of my mind i
rode city bikes all day i
did a sick leg workout earlier six a.m
[ __ ] mad pre-workout i feel great and
you went running around
the city with your wife feeling like
you're 16.
that's what i'm saying doing all kinds
of crazy [ __ ]
you know almost sexual acts
you just kissed a lot and touch good man
i do that with my girl all the time
that's what it's about man you know we
don't get to do that we have a brand new
baby and it's like you know
we're just running around running the
muck i'd shave my face so no one would
recognize me
a little mustache though yeah i was a
little like a little sailor
how long do you have that beard for i
always have a beard i don't know since i
was three
and then since you came out the womb he
had a beard
straight up what am i going to do i was
born this way lady gaga
wow so then you when did you shave the
other day i took it off it was really
high and i ruined the shape up you know
when you [ __ ] it up
you know it's just like they gotta all
come off are you like i just decided to
leave a little yeah i like
well now i don't have 17 shoes so it's
like
i kind of have a sculpted look it looks
good
yeah thank you it's kind of if you
didn't know me it'd be like yo that
dude's kind of sculpted
yeah yeah i did he looks like a swimmer
are you still losing weight every day is
that like uh are you at the weight that
you want to be
nah i'm gonna lose another 15 or so but
right now i've been around
248 245 for like five months now
which is really good for me because i
fluctuate a lot
and the fact that i've been able to stay
stable and still
enjoy life and have a normal lifestyle
and not be [ __ ]
out of my mind over food you know what i
mean it's not it's like
you know it's like being sober bro it's
like you know you [ __ ]
you get off the [ __ ] you just [ __ ] do
other [ __ ] you stop thinking about it
it's completely like that and dude i i
got my own
struggles dude like i remember when that
when the joaquin phoenix
uh joker movie came out i was sitting in
the movie theater i had a whole [ __ ]
big tub of caramel popcorn and i got
mist fulls of i'm putting fistfuls of
caramel popcorn in my mouth
and then chewing it all up with a jumbo
pack of red vines
and i ate the whole jumbo pancakes by
the way it's a delicious combo because
that's phenomenal
yeah and i i ate all of it and i'm
sitting there thinking like [ __ ] dude
that's my rock bottom you know and that
wasn't even like particularly unusual
for me man like
i would be like i had this one day i'm
like oh dude i can't go to this one
[ __ ] supermarket like because
i know i'm gonna buy a cake so i'll go
to this other one
and then i'm at the other one and and i
get in line and
and i see they got like [ __ ] fun a
big
jumbo [ __ ] bag of fun-sized
butterfingers and it says it says
each little [ __ ] fun-sized
butterfinger's only 100 calories
and i'm like it's only 100 so i bought
it and it ate the whole bag
it now that this is going back this is
all back when that juan king phoenix
movie came out so we're like
pushing a couple years almost and then
like i finally
[ __ ] rock bottom man and i reached
out to a buddy of mine who i knew was in
the food program like a full 12-step
fellowship for food [ __ ] and like i dove
into that man i had like every meal i
ate i [ __ ] took pictures of it i sent
it to this guy for approval
that like the rule was no [ __ ] sugar
no flour
like and i stuck to that for almost an
entire year
and then [ __ ] one time out with my
with my lady
and the the waitress at this restaurant
says like oh hey we had an
extra dessert so like we're just going
to leave it here and i was going to give
it to you because it was someone ordered
it went to the wrong table
i took one [ __ ] bite dude and i'm off
the rails again dude
what was it what'd you eat so they let
so you told me they laid that dessert on
someone else's table took it off that
table and put it on your table i mean
you might forget what it was somebody
like ordered the wrong thing or like
they just ended up with an extra [ __ ]
dessert it was a lava cake
so like and it's just crazy damn when
you said that
i just saw the [ __ ] ooze of
chocolates like that
my hands are sweating dude dude yeah nah
i just got hard
and and that's the thing i remember back
in the day before i got sober i would be
like
trying trying to [ __ ] quit cocaine
and
and i remember like i i'm one time i
made it like slightly over a year
without doing cocaine
and then my buddy just [ __ ] gives me
gives me a little
like and you can't
cocaine and like sugary products is that
like a big deal i mean
i me anything that i'm addicted to right
no but does it work well together like
if you do coke you want to eat like
suck on like you want to eat candy when
you're [ __ ] cooked
you don't want to eat no right you want
to eat your own gums is what you want to
do
like what you want like if you're if
you're
[ __ ] just do the coke first then you
need a drink of alcohol to take the edge
off
and if you have a [ __ ] drink first
then you need a pump of coke to [ __ ]
you know like you just got to be even
everything has to even out at all
well then it's bedtime and you got to do
a zany bar big time
oh yeah and that's the thing it's like
any [ __ ]
common sense like like rational thinking
would be like
oh i haven't done cocaine for a year and
i did it the one time like
like i should [ __ ] not do that
anymore but once you open that door just
a little crack
the whole [ __ ] gorilla comes out and
that's what happened with that lava cake
man
like ever since then and i think twice
dude i'm out of control man like what am
i
you know like dude i was just on family
vacation and my niece went to the
bathroom and i've been on a diet trying
to lose weight
because i read the [ __ ] comments on
one of the youtube videos
and the guy said did scott randolph get
stung by all the bees
i'm just kind of hurt by it but like
thank you because it's
dude i was gaining weight you know so
[ __ ] it and then like yeah now you have
to be
shamed that we were talking about this
the other day we have to be
shaved yeah and so like you know so i've
been trying to lose some weight
and then my niece went to the bathroom
and she had a corn dog and french fries
on the table
i ate one french fry and then i [ __ ]
ate the rest of her french fries
and then she came back crying because
somebody ate all her french fries i
can't just have one and it's [ __ ]
crazy
who the [ __ ] did you say ate them you
said someone came by and ate them you
didn't
stop it i just said i'm sorry i'll buy
you like a [ __ ] shaved ice from
hawaii
you know what i mean oh man she was
crying
i'd be crying too i hate when that [ __ ]
happens she needs to know better not to
leave the food unattended come on guys
i mean get it together you know scott
what's wrong with him
there's been times where you have like
like i ordered
i have like four or five like 20
different places that know my [ __ ]
order by heart
you'll call up the spot yo how you doing
oh sesame chicken they'll [ __ ] laugh
at you
yeah what i'm saying like literally
[ __ ]
laugh at you with your order after
knowing exactly what you want
that's where it's like kind of like yo
what the [ __ ] am i doing i order this
every day and they're laughing at me
knowing my order [ __ ] everybody knows
what i'm getting
they know i'm getting the sesame chicken
they know i'm getting [ __ ] big ziti
pizza
now you got now you've been changing
your orders though right
now i don't know what around man i just
i eat at home uh-huh
i eat at home and i make food or i
consciously you know
try and get wholesome stuff there's no
need to be eating [ __ ] the whole pack
of oreos with
three mexican cokes i know dude jesus
yeah but the mexican coke has no need
for that
now mexican cokes have real sugar yeah
real sugar
american cook has uh [ __ ] think about
that
mexican coke and oreos make pigeons
explode
what is it doing to me it makes my chin
explode out so i have another chin
that's so crazy [ __ ] bloated up dude
human beings are so [ __ ]
you know right with their diets and like
you go into a denny's late at like two
in the morning and like
you know you are what you eat people
sometimes that's an inspiration that
two in the morning denny's is
desperation
mess dude i used to go to denny's at two
in the morning
to do freelance bus boy work
meaning i would go around the tables and
eat the [ __ ] that people left
what you were you okay so you're walking
hot i was [ __ ] hungry i was homeless
i didn't have any [ __ ] money and i i
wanted to eat so i went to denny's and i
walked around and like
got to the table before the boy so i
couldn't eat what was left on people's
plates okay that's what i did
was a freelance bus boy yeah
so denny's didn't know you that you
worked for them teddy's had no idea
i'm like damn that's pretty cool if
denny's like hook you up late at night
no
yeah that's funny dude oh there's no
denny's in the city man
i've the only denny's i ever go to a
[ __ ] like lowly little [ __ ]
denny's like
on the road [ __ ] group 60 god damn
who the hell knows
heavy it's heavy dude it's heavy when
you're on the road and you stop at these
little places it's heavy duty well the
light just shines so nice and bright
when you're on when you see the denny's
far off into the distance
yeah well yeah there's a lot of those
symbols that i like
scott's my tour manager when uh no [ __ ]
yeah when i go around doing uh doing my
comedy tour
yeah we have how do you find tour
managing
what's that how do you like to tour
manage you enjoy the job i like it i
like multitasking i like booking the
flights the hotels like kind of it calms
me to sit down
at like you know early in the morning
and just map out things and then get the
merge coordinated and
you got a [ __ ] guy you got your guy
man he likes doing it that's it boom you
[ __ ] thrive and that's that there's a
lot of people that are just not good
dude scott perfectly compliments like
my he fills in my gaps yeah i love that
yeah he likes working just as hard just
as much as i do and i like working just
as you know what i mean
i mean it's sunday night fuel it that's
it come on man what's on an action
bronson writer
when you're when you're touring yeah i
love
that scott asks every single touring
artist we ever talked to that question
you know what i don't love
administrative duties
i was not born to be an office clerk and
frankly
i am not very well equipped to take care
of
all of my insurance needs i need a
babysitter
right i mean my eyes just glaze over and
that's why i need
help and where do i get the help i get
it from
policy genius.com what is it
it's like virtual one-stop shopping
for all kinds of insurance health
insurance auto insurance
home insurance the list goes on and on
and when you go on there and compare
quotes
for example you could save up to 50
on your life insurance we're talking
like 1300 bucks a year
man it's very well worth it it is very
easy to do
all in one spot i'm telling you guys man
it is the help that i need to go through
life
in short man you don't want to be a dumb
dumb get insured man
and get insured very easily with the
beautiful babysitting that they give you
at policy genius.com
because when it comes to insurance it is
nice to get it right
isn't it all right policygenius.com
thank you for making it so easy
now let's talk about that rider i keep
it light you know it depends where i am
sometimes i ask for a vitamix
sometimes i'll ask for a [ __ ] a
basketball hoop
and most of the time it's just sicilian
yeah it's just sicilian pistachios
and essential water that's it and baby
wipes for that ass
yeah dude and q-tips for my bong
so when i clean the bomb you know what i
mean it's i got to use
specific tools to keep it precision you
bring your own bong you don't have them
bring you one no i bring my own i like i
like to
carry my own rig yeah
that's funny we got into we got into
smoking hookah and and we started part
of our rider was like a little hookah
set up
it's like you're like a bunch of
dominican guys smoking hookah you just
[ __ ]
take the hookah you set it up in the
trunk of the car and
five of you stand around and hit it yeah
right on [ __ ] have a meyer in south
second
right here in williamsburg it's the best
[ __ ] ever i literally
pull over pop out yo let me hit that hit
some cherry hookah
and go get a slice of pizza and go home
it's it's
unbelievably enjoyable man we were in
morocco
not even that long ago man i love
morocco yeah and then
we're at this nice [ __ ] hotel set up
on the roof they got the
the rooftop [ __ ] cool music and like
they bring you the hookah and i'm like
you know phenomenal i'm like super
people [ __ ] smoke hookah it's not
like a [ __ ]
you know a big deal it's not a drug you
know it's like i'm in morocco
just sat there and [ __ ] smoked it for
like two days straight dude and then
when i got home
[ __ ] landed it well first we
connected in london and we went and
[ __ ] like
begged them to [ __ ] they were closing
at like 12 you like you know in the
restaurant business when like
everybody's wrapping up cleaning up
and they're just like and then the
people are like knocking at the door
like and you're just like [ __ ] these
people
like will they you know people are like
[ __ ] it some people
take the business yeah well this girl
wanted to go home
and like i feel it i feel it how did i
talk him into it
i was like i'll [ __ ] pay i'll pay you
like they throw money at them
we probably you know we then we probably
like just threw money in the air
yeah please
it was a it was a pitiful embarrassing
[ __ ]
desperate like move to smoke hookah in
london
and then then we get on the airplane and
fly to l.a
and like i got the car taking me home
and i'm like dude
[ __ ] pull over i [ __ ] pulled over
and bought a [ __ ] hookah
to to bring to my [ __ ] house i just
sat there for
weeks just i'm like dude what am i doing
what am i doing and i go on tour and
they gotta [ __ ] have a hookah in my
green room
oh yeah well what's even more impressive
was like we were at the rooftop in
morocco and we had like a you know a
good hour session of just blasting
hookahs all day
and then i'm like woozy going back to my
hotel room and then
he's going back down for a second
session and i'm just like holy [ __ ]
dude yeah oh my god the hookah sesh man
gotta throw some hash in that [ __ ] [ __ ]
i can't dude i can't do that i know not
you
you you i know dude when you're on tour
you too don't [ __ ]
i'll throw hash in mine yeah you just
watch
that's what i was doing in morocco
you're just putting the hash and
whatever you could just whatever you
could find just sprinkle hash
i was smoking straight up somehow we got
a couple of dutch masters in morocco
and i've just [ __ ] rolled the fattest
[ __ ] cigar filled with hash and just
was holding it upside down like this
smoking it
it was [ __ ] great
yeah the lean mean tagine hell yeah
so dude we were in the same movie
together you and me
the [ __ ] word the game over man movie
oh that's right you remember that [ __ ]
the netflix one man
so you went out to vancouver yeah i was
in vancouver [ __ ] had me out
there for nine
hours to do a five-minute [ __ ] spiel
i was pissed yeah and i was besides
myself but [ __ ] what's his name was
there
[ __ ] daniel stern okay
you remember fool from [ __ ] home
alone and city slickers
oh yeah yeah of course all right so he
was there so i was getting a kick out of
that
right beyond for nine hours i could have
done so i could have done that for an
hour got a kick out of it and gotten
home the the thing was though
that like they could only start shooting
once the sun went down
and so they start the nine-hour day at
like
[ __ ] it was like summertime so it's
like [ __ ] 9 p.m
when you start so you don't get out of
there until like 6 a.m that's what made
the nine hours even harsher
yeah i was sick to my stomach you're so
bad it was a good time
yeah i was i was stoked that happened to
me [ __ ]
uh king of staten island too it was
[ __ ] 12 hours i was in the goddamn
trailer eating ellen b
spimoni three times i was like bro i
live
[ __ ] 20 minutes away come on
and what about what about i left i left
i left and came back i was just [ __ ]
crazy
how was your experience on the irishman
who
i mean you talk about professionalism
[ __ ] five minutes i was in and out
yeah
five minutes in and out scorsese and de
niro
wow [ __ ] [ __ ] myth what's it
called
thank you man [ __ ] nine hours
vancouver
game over man nine [ __ ] hours yeah
nothing scorsese
10 minutes me and deniro done
wow like [ __ ] he nailed it he's like
he called it i'm the second one that i
did like yo you nailed it
i don't know what i did
[Laughter]
but all i know is that i had a good time
all of these things were a good time
it's all
like i'm just [ __ ] around but
doing movies i know it's still tedious
and [ __ ] if you're getting paid you're
getting paid i wasn't getting [ __ ]
paid that much so that's why i was
pissed yeah
yeah that makes sense man how was that
did you shoot the staten island thing
before
kobe do you have to yeah that [ __ ] was
yeah of course yeah it was a long time
ago
that was when [ __ ] was still yeah that
was right here in new york bill burr
showed up at the show and he had the
mustache
oh that's what he was shooting yeah yeah
yeah
dude the uh billboard is the man yeah
the [ __ ] king of staten island and i
noticed it because it came out
during the pandemics and they got it on
all the things and i'm like wait a
second
rent on itunes for [ __ ] like 19.99
yeah like 20 did you believe that [ __ ]
it was
that was like one of the first movies
that i saw that it was like a
new version of a release and that kind
of
ushered in the way things are now kind
of done
right right yeah it's kind of crazy but
because it made a lot of noise i
remember it was a [ __ ] big deal i was
like how the [ __ ] are people gonna watch
this [ __ ]
i don't even know how to order it right
i know how to do it from back in the day
not now but not only was it 1999 but it
seemed like [ __ ]
everybody was ordering it well everybody
was in the pandemic and then you had
another movie
so you had king of staten island and the
irishman
killer movies in the [ __ ] pandemic
pretty unbelievable
it was crazy i mean we got to do the
we got to do the whole red carpet thing
i met pesci i met
chino next level yeah the irishman was
during the pandemic right
well it had we shot a while back
but it took like a year and a half to
[ __ ] do it and then
it came out during that which was
another like it was a big netflix thing
they didn't do it
you know what not we did we did the the
lincoln center opening
i remember that yo bro i'm not good with
remembering [ __ ]
i remember like 94 nicks that's it
oh dude yeah so you got you got we got
more acting [ __ ] coming up
i hope so i hope so i'm just trying to
get him where i fit in
do my thing break the mold yeah no one
has their thumb
on me i'm not just one thing how about
from everything
you got any uh tour announcements coming
up
yeah man i'm [ __ ] uh we're trying to
announce a show in coney island soon in
august hopefully
which is a big deal for me first new
york show in a long time i haven't
performed in a [ __ ] minute
i got portugal in july trying to be
bodyboarding in the [ __ ] ocean with
all my homies
and the nazarene big waves exactly in
[ __ ] naturally straight up i mean not
during those big ass ways during a
normal day
yeah yeah during a normal day yeah
that's good
i heard you're a big bodybuilder oh man
it's one of my this mother i wish that i
[ __ ] could redo things
and just do that forever where's your
favorite place the body board
i gotta find out right now [ __ ]
rockaway robert moses state park in new
york you know
rockaway and queens and robert moses
state park long island
yes this place in jersey called jenks
jenkinson's on the boardwalk it's
supposed to be the best bodyboarding
wave on the east coast i got [ __ ]
spiked
straight down there it was amazing yeah
we we're looking for a good spot to go
surf with the uh the statue of liberty
in the background is that possible
well i got my homie you could come to
the indoor surf spot
in jersey at the mall at the american
dream wall my man will train you if you
want
he has it's the only indoor wave pool in
the world
wow like what kind of wave pool like the
stream thing like they got on cruise
ships nah nah this literally makes
ocean waves it's some crazy technology
that he could create like 20 different
waves
wow real deal like
three four feet okay or waco
yeah it's similar to the waco thing but
indoors damn
that's [ __ ] kind of dope yes i would
love that that's in jersey
that's in jersey yes dude let's all meet
up
i want to do the waco one too i was just
in austin and i was gonna go do it but
at that time
but i'm trying to go to waco also yeah
dude i'm trying to go to kelly slater
i'm trying to do all these shits i'm
trying to do all that [ __ ] crazy [ __ ]
dude i've been just killing slaters
twice
man i've been sick right it's
unbelievable unbelievable
yeah he got the wave of the day they
gave him the truth
i was in the barrel brushing my mustache
dude yeah
shady i love i love it yeah so uh
you've been to how many uh ufc events
have you been to
[ __ ] i i'm like over 10 now
a lot yeah i just i love that [ __ ]
i love it i've been watching ufc since
its inception
because my boy had the his we used to
watch all the pay-per-views on
on cable you know the wrestling
pay-per-views and then
his father had the box where he got
every channel so you get all that [ __ ]
for free
and we he'd like come over and watch
this [ __ ]
so we'd watch [ __ ] some crazy
ultimate fighting and then
when it wasn't on we go to [ __ ]
blockbuster video
yeah on parsons boulevard and go rent
that [ __ ] so it was like we're watching
it
it was like craziness from the beginning
like what the hell is going on
i remember i i had a job in a video
store freelance
i i legit worked there and and my job
was to go like
take the [ __ ] uh the rental return
box and like
empty it out and then put all the videos
back on the shelves
and they have like a whole ufc section
and i was like
what the [ __ ] is this you know like what
the [ __ ] is this
and i and i watched it and i didn't get
into it back then so much man because
all the red like the rounds would go for
like 25 minutes and the rest
yeah the rest some of it was weird but
there were some highlights that were
dope you know when they would show you
like the best of and then there was some
japan stuff
yeah it was like i always i was one of
those guys that
when i went to the event i would buy the
vhs
like the crazy [ __ ] like [ __ ] from japan
so i would go to like extreme
championship wrestling events in queens
when i was like 12 13 years old 14 years
old at the elks lodge on queens
boulevard and i'd buy the cactus jack
versus terry funk from
japan barbed wire fire thumbtack
[ __ ] shards of glass match
that you wouldn't be able to see unless
you got these vhs so
yeah i [ __ ] love that [ __ ] so i was
always into the extreme sports
i was always into like we'd always
wrestle each other and do extreme
wrestling jumping off cars doing [ __ ]
flying elbow drops into people's faces
and [ __ ]
good times yeah hurting each other
really bad like out of nowhere in school
you [ __ ] catch someone with a stone
cold stunner
for sure i remember i [ __ ] bruised my
tailbone from stuttering people too many
i just sat
wrong you know i fell right on my ass
yeah no good did you ever see the
documentary the smashing machine
about no dude this is fun this is a big
[ __ ] deal
marker yeah yeah the smashing machine
wait is that the one the rock dude
the rock is getting ready to to oh so
that didn't happen yet this is something
that's already occurred
the og one while he was fighting like
when was that like ninety
nine i don't even wanna he's a [ __ ]
animal that dude
i don't remember for you it's the most
incredible [ __ ] documentary it was
made by hbo it's called the smashing
machine
really the story of mark bro let's talk
about [ __ ]
hbo documentaries do you remember gang
banging in little rock
i don't but i do remember high on crack
street
hookers at the point
yeah it was mental i i sampled from
methadone
it's [ __ ] in one of my projects blue
chips too i have a methadone
[ __ ] insert on there dude that
[ __ ]
[ __ ] did liquid handcuffs dude method
methadone is [ __ ]
dude i like that oh that's just [ __ ]
yeah hp
dude all documentaries is what i'm about
man i [ __ ] with documentaries dude i'm
actually having a crisis right now
because i don't know what [ __ ]
documentary
series to watch on netflix or whatever
else like i'm out of them
yeah there's not none right and name a
dope ass documentary series i [ __ ]
watched it
let me hear it have you watched the the
the seven
five oh yeah of course of course
dirty cops in new york michael dowd you
of course you know about it yeah
yeah i watched that years back dude yeah
yeah i
i just i always bring that one back i
bring it back every year i love watching
it's like sopranos i have to watch it
twice a year yeah it's fantastic for the
wire
the wire i didn't really [ __ ] with
because like fiction man like i
i don't really [ __ ] care about fake
[ __ ] that didn't actually happen
man like that's why i want to watch the
documentary [ __ ] you know like
did you watch on netflix the one i was
called the pharmacist
where the [ __ ] no i haven't been
watching a lot of [ __ ] to be honest with
you
dude you're in a great position man
there's a lot of good [ __ ] out there
dude
the pharmacist is about a guy who's
[ __ ] worked in a pharmacy he was like
an
older man and like he had
his uh like he noticed everybody coming
in with these oxy
prescriptions and like then all of a
sudden his son died he's trying to like
solve his son's murder but then he's
like it's all tied together
and so he's like i'm going after the
whole [ __ ]
like pharmaceutical [ __ ] drug dealing
thing and and like you don't even know
at the beginning
of it where it's going to go but he's
taking on the whole [ __ ]
world now he's dead no no no now there's
a [ __ ]
like a resolution to the company that
makes the oxies oh really
yeah except the [ __ ] thing is nobody
got charged with any criminal
thing and it's like they got slapped
with like a fine which is like
[ __ ] crumbs of what they make that so
it's all
just that's crazy that opioid epidemic
is no joke
i'm lucky i never got into that type of
[ __ ] i was always too fat for coke
i never really liked pills needles you
gotta [ __ ] run after me to put the
needle in my finger to get a little
prick
you know what i'm saying like i'm not
into that type of [ __ ]
always just like smoking [ __ ] smoking
that week
yeah dude smoking that [ __ ]
weed
it's so it's so simple it's like old
parents do that [ __ ] you don't
see like parents [ __ ] tying off and
[ __ ] like that unless
you know certain parents tie off but you
know until about you know i didn't see
any of my friends parents tying off
yeah dude so you smoke weed
what do you uh what do you think about
social media dude are you [ __ ]
like addicted to your phone i am
yeah everyone's addicted to the phone
i'll take a video of myself [ __ ]
bodyboarding and watch it 700 times for
analyzation purposes
dude a lot it's all i'm [ __ ] i'm
swinging a kettlebell in here this
morning
six a.m [ __ ] analyzing my form
that's all it is for me all social media
is is an
analyzation of my form
do you get the same things that happened
with steve is like i can post a picture
of steve sleeping he'll get
10 000 likes but like we'll go travel
across the world
four four planes later get the most epic
surfing shop
the most epic surfing shot and nobody
gives a [ __ ] about it
yeah it's like yeah i think the
algorithms [ __ ] bro i think there's
something wrong i think instagram
doesn't show certain [ __ ] to be honest
with you
why is this more popular than this why
is it but that's if you give a [ __ ]
if you're looking and i don't really
give a [ __ ] i put it up there and i
leave it alone
yeah i like videos i like looking at
[ __ ] i'm addicted to looking at i'm
addicted to being over stimulated
that's what i'm addicted to i got your
kettlebell video right here man i just
hit you
i had to hit your ig man i'm [ __ ]
following you on there there it is
[ __ ] let's go hey let me ask you
something because you had that
block let me ask you something because
you had that ancient alien
tv show what did you you heard that
they're coming out with like
uh some intel june 1st do you know
anything about that
[ __ ] what they're saying okay we'll
admit it ufos are real and that's coming
out june 1st
i mean whoa whoa ufos are real
whoa [ __ ] blowing my mind
i already know you're not coming out
with any [ __ ] they're not coming out
with anything crazy
they're not telling me any [ __ ]
things that's gonna blow my mind
they're not gonna [ __ ] tell me that
like [ __ ] patrick ewing was related
to bob marley that would blow my mind
you know that's
that's not what they're gonna tell us
yeah
all right when did your book come out
i'm going to help you promote some [ __ ]
i know you don't give a [ __ ] but
i'm not really sure 420 oh it came out
420. there you go
okay now can i urge you to
do the [ __ ] audio book man if it's
only 150 pages man then
then [ __ ] it won't take you long to
read it i think there's a lot of [ __ ]
people who
don't want to physically read [ __ ] and
they want to be able to listen to it
while they drive
i know man we gotta understand that it
triggered me
and i would have done it if it wasn't
triggered i went to therapy literally
that day that's why i threw everybody
out
i got triggered and i had to talk it out
so i felt like it wasn't worth my grief
that's really all it is if you want me
to be totally honest
and that's leaving it all out there yeah
that's cool because we both go to
therapy too
i love talking about that [ __ ] dude yeah
i mean you know like
i i was totally i was definitely not
with it but my lady forced me
she thought that it would be good for me
and it was she was right
yeah yeah she was right i'm
i'm one of those people that just
[ __ ] i've stored away
and just continue to keep going just
doing what i do and just keep storing
shirky eye
just letting it just not dealing with
things you know right
i deal with it through i forget about it
by drawing a picture
[ __ ] writing a musical [ __ ]
composition of raps
that's how i forget [ __ ] good man
and uh the season five of the [ __ ]
that's delicious yeah well i will
100 plug this this [ __ ] that's delicious
is my pride and joy my baby
you know i built that [ __ ] from
the ground from the first day i uttered
those words
you know what i mean now it is 100
completely in my control
independently funded by myself so
as many people as you [ __ ] were
watching before because it was on some
big network or whatever the case may be
make sure that you support now because
it's that same person
that same [ __ ] passion that same
quality
it's just all produced by me in-house no
[ __ ] big willing [ __ ]
good man where'd uh where did people
find it
on my youtube channel just action
bronson okay boom
a bunch of good stuff up there all kinds
of content coming
what else am i doing yeah well you
[ __ ]
help me man where you got the you got
the shows coming up in in coney island
in portugal you got the [ __ ] book is
called
coney island and portugal i'm coming for
you
yeah and i'm trying to [ __ ] string
together some shows in between that
let's see what the [ __ ] opens let's go
come on like in between
we got to make some things happen before
that yeah
and other than that i don't know i'm not
really sure what's going on what's
happening
i'm working right now i'm working right
now on a new album
new music will be here by the end of the
year hopefully
all kinds of new art stuff paintings
[ __ ] like that
whatever i got just dropped a beautiful
olive oil
i always do i do olive oil four times a
year so everybody should make sure they
check that out
because it sells out really quickly and
it's really phenomenally delicious
and it's always of the freshest freshest
time it's harvested at that moment's
peak performance normal playing games
where's the where are the olives from
this one was from tuscany
this was the the perfect expression of a
friend toyo
a field blend from from tuscany i love
it
yeah i've done one from south africa
we've done from chile we've done from
from hyenas to spain from
where else from sicily
aloes are grown all over the world and
there's really tremendous versions of
all these
of all these things all these
all this oil all over so we just source
it and
and bring it to the peeps italian people
are healthier because they [ __ ] with
more olive oil
it's a proven fact it helped me one
million percent i
[ __ ] i i will 100 say that olive oil
adding olive oil strictly to my diet has
changed
my body composition my brain function
100 i guarantee it it's no [ __ ] you
know you drink filippo berrio from the
store you're gonna
taste like [ __ ] and feel actually
because it's not real [ __ ]
this is pure unfiltered coming
directly out of the machine into a
bottle brought to you by me
from my man nick coleman who was
literally the top oleologist in the
world where his
only passion in life besides many things
olive oil so where do people say what he
cares about
that's what he does for a living where
can we find your olive oil
well you can find my olive oil four
times a year
you can find out by following me and
[ __ ]
all right it always comes out on
grovenvine.com
you can check check my website and stuff
like that i don't even have a website
check my [ __ ] that thing instagram
check instagram look at the post read
some [ __ ] about it
do some research dude i love it man
bamba baklava
that's right bam bam boom boom ah bam
bam baklava
that's right you would try to say it was
like a foreign word
yeah dude bam bam baklava all right
that's good man
all right well [ __ ] you're killing it
man i love your confidence dude i love
uh
much love you're the man you're not
you're not you're not one [ __ ] thing
you're all over the place you're
whatever you want
and you don't give a [ __ ] i don't give a
[ __ ] i love
everything i don't give a [ __ ] i'm
passionate i chill
yeah dude well hey man i i i dig it man
i dig it
and uh thank you for doing this man i
got john
[ __ ] uh which means you can hit me up
anytime
[ __ ] uh you go you'll go right in
there because i'm following you
hit me up get away man let's go [ __ ]
surf there's just surf indoor waves i
would
surf indoor outdoor whatever a river
will go into a [ __ ] river and surf
that i've never served a river all right
brother well hey man [ __ ] like i'm
not gonna have any time and thank you
for this man
thank you guys take care dude
yeah dude what a cool guy man and thank
you
for sticking around this long to be here
at the end of the episode
you know if you've been paying attention
to all these episodes you'll know that
i've been talking about getting into
vlogging
and i'm real serious about that i got my
guy jack
who i hired to follow me around and make
these
vlog videos we got our first one going
live tomorrow dude i'm committed to that
i'd be waiting to see how i do vlogging
yeah dude